ich will nicht ich will nicht zu ende
mit luka auf dieser tollen insel wo ich
auch extrem gerne einfach gerade wäre
stattdessen sitze ich hier in meiner
wohnung in köln der erste morgen und
direkt meldet sich lana wieder zu wort
guten morgen
das ist bisher keine regelverstöße
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicht mal harry hatte was mit francesca
oder wie das wetter wird sonnig mit bis
zu 28 grad celsius und 0 aussicht diese
lana die trigger die auch immer extrem
ist hier das mich extrem triggert ich
habe mir selbst ist musik gemacht und
der schmeckt noch mal alles für die
gesundheit
das ist wie der schlimmste horror film
aller zeiten
du kriegst hunderttausend euro dafür
wenn du einen monat keinen spaß also in
meinen augen ist das alles andere als
horrorfilm
aber es ist halt harry als wenn man
nicht mal ich bin mir nicht warum der
erste satz diene zu diesem bericht
beigetragen habe ich schon falsch ist
dir echt und falsch der erste satz der
ja doch
[Musik]
kein wunder aber keine überraschung
schließlich ist jesus hier
[Musik]
netflix wenn ihr noch ein cutter sucht
für die nächste staffel ich bin safe
dabei ich habe so bock das zuschneiden
für euch ihr regeln haben uns die nacht
vermasselt francesca und ich haben nur
gekuschelt und uns unterhalten
aber heute ist mir so was von egal
[Musik]
harry sagt hier direkt zu beginn der
folge dass er eine regel ein sorry dass
ich euch ja so viele szenen und wörter
zensieren uns allerdings wird das video
sonst leider gesperrt werden wie youtube
das schon bei einigen anderen youtube an
und auch bei mir bei einigen videos
bereits in letzter zeit getan hat ich
weiß nicht warum die gerade den kurzen
eng ziehen mit werbe freundlichkeit und
mit sperrungen und keine ahnung was aber
es tut mir leid ich möchte das auch
nicht aber ich darf euch wohl
anscheinend nicht mal mehr eine nackte
schulter zeigen also es tut mir leid für
die ganze sensor in dem video zufolge
weniger preisgeld
also dürfen kuscheln jetzt so schön da
wo die wünsche des spitzen singles
müssen sich also im selbstbeherrschung
üben um herauszufinden wie es ist eine
echte beziehung haar in diesem resort
die heißesten menschen der ganzen welt
versammelt
[Musik]
jetzt schon mal eine glühbirne ein
bisschen und bedrückt mich glory hat die
ansicht dass in diesem ressort die zehn
hübschesten menschen auf der kompletten
welt sind froh bin ich da nein ist
teamorder
nein also beruhigt dich wir dürfen uns
nicht mal küsst noch die cases not a lot
ganz einfach wir lassen einfach die
hosen an
[Musik]
meine einsteigen
kosten jetzt hier der virologe ne
quatsch die knie
also ich weiß wenn ich uns schon geld
koste dann aber richtig haben es muss
sich ja schließlich lohnt erst recht
wenn du doch ein vergehen machst dann
würde ich das oder ist es dann so
gestaffelt dass man sagt okay jetzt hat
er schon vergeben gemacht weil sie also
werden die die hatte ich denn jetzt was
ich mich einfach generell frage ist
nehmen wir beispielsweise an harry und
francesca haben müssen die dann für
diesen quasi ihre strafe bezahlen und
alles andere was darunter ist von der
strafe wenn sie sich währenddessen noch
küssen kommt noch und ob oder ist dann
da mit drin weil er schon die höchste
strafe ist ist er doch mal interessant
zu wissen aber wir schauen einfach mal
weiter
am anfang hatte ich meinen augen front
geworfen aber klar und ich haben so ein
hitziges hin und her am laufen
ich möchte sie besser kennen ok ich
möchte sie besser kennenlernen es ist ja
schon mal ein richtiger weg in die
richtung die emotionale beziehung zu
führen komplett ohne ohne alles ich mal
kosten für 100000 dollar es ist als
würde man superhelden auf einen planeten
schicken
denn dass die lektion ist die lange
unter teilen möchte wähle ich auf jeden
fall das geld ich würde richtig sauer
wenn mir das jemand versaut hält denkt
krass der denkt nicht mit seinem sondern
hier da oben also nicht mit seinem
haaransatz nicht mal das ganz ehrlich
für mich wird das wirklich schwer aber
es geht ums wohl der gruppe und das
zählt einfach mehr als persönliche
dürfen
warte mal heißt das
300.000 euro
ich dachte jeder olaf er so viel budget
die wahrscheinlich auch nicht das wären
eine million euro
die sind schon in einem übels kranken
luxus-resort irgend einer einsamen insel
das macht es noch interessanter
das heißt wenn harry und francesca sich
nicht beherrschen können leiden auch die
anderen darunter max
es ist nicht einfach so lange ohne
jegliche form befriedigung auszukommen
aber ich sage es ganz deutlich matthew
ist ab jetzt in lana steam
planer rückwärts altana natürlich ist
jesus lanners erster jünger wie lange
kann ich das gute in leuten sehen die
ständig selbstsüchtig handeln
eine lage gerade nicht mit jesus nicht
du hast dich ja schon genauso an das von
thomas spitzname den ich dem zu beginn
gegeben habe aber jetzt konkret aussieht
jedoch an die kinder
sie wollen immer tun dass sie nicht
dürfen
es interessant es stellt sich direkt
raus das herz und matthew wer
beobachtend agieren und er so analytisch
und strategisch an die sache rangehen
während
unser rugbyspieler und unter anderem die
lampe die amerikaner gehen sollen
achtung beiden machen hier so jesus ich
frage mich wenn er halt also wen er auch
abkriegen würde weil irgendwie hat sich
herausgestellt dass alle auf harry
stehen und of kells
david
und keiner steht halt auf jesus
irgendwie obwohl er halt noch mal jesus
ist ich finde erinnerungen sind mehr
wert als hunderttausend dollar diese
veränderungen sind unbezahlt erinnerung
erinnerung
also ich glaube zu
in beiden darf ich habe mal einen blick
in lenas liebes handtuch geworfen und
weiß wo er gäste erwartet als jungs
crashkurs der siam und hat tiefere
verbindungen einzugehen moment
aber wir wissen noch immer nicht wie
teuer jetzt welches vergehen ist
workshop wollen die auch machen
er weiß ich habe angst der reine liebe
zu finden an das wir
das wäre
richtig pädagogisch die serie
anscheinend die war was
die bekommen auch noch jeder eine
private suite dks aber schon frech die
drückende ja so richtig in die richtung
und die stehen da die diesen film robbie
ich frage mich was harry zum land
geplant hat da bin ich jetzt
ausgesprochen und wissen dass ich es
ernst meine
ok krass
[Musik]
geht man einfach nie enttäuscht ich bin
so genervt weil ich ihn küssen will und
es nicht da es ist so frustrierend
hunderttausend dollar ja
auch rugby verwechsle ich das sogar
schon passen die sich jetzt aber nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die erste aber richtige regelverstoß
meine lieben leute das geld geht runter
frage ist nur um wie viel fortschritt 30
cent und jetzt richtig dumme plot ist
alle küsten oder die ganze zeit darüber
der ganze sinn was keinem wirklich
verstehen sie wo harry hat seinen kuss
bekommen jetzt
ich würde gerne erstmal wissen wie teuer
das jetzt war für die alle noch wissen
sie nicht wie teuer dieser regelverstoß
war da wird ihnen die rechnung sich
arbeit verlieren höher ist kussmund
bitte also in der heutigen folge haben
wir gelernt dass harry und francesca
schon mal die gruppe geld gekostet haben
und die auch gerade gesagt haben alle
zusammen hunderttausend euro und nicht
jeder einzelne was die ganze
gruppendynamik auch noch mal ein
bisschen verändert an der stelle würde
ich allerdings meine mittlerweile schon
vierten reaction auf diese serie to how
to handle jetzt auch beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat und unbedingt einen
fünften teil
haben wollt dann lasst die daumen hoch
unter dem video das schaffen wir 30.000
likes das sollten wir es hinkriegen
glaube ich oder ihr seid die lupe das
ist eigentlich dass sie das hinkriegt
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon in der endart meine lieben freunde
wenn ich hier oben auf den smiley
draufsteht könnte man kann kostenlos
abonniert dann verpasse keine videos
mehr und wenn ich schon seit klicken auf
die glocke damit kommt in der
benachrichtigung auf euer handy wenn ich
das nächste mal ein video hochladen die
beispielsweise hier bei der nächsten
action und jetzt ein video was eben auch
meinen zwei kindern online gegangen ist